alors allez ça et david est ce que vous
regardez l'émission voir un petit peu
alors oui cette année ça visiblement non
valley siaba regardez pas le problème
c'est qu'il ya son mec qui lui dit
qu'est ce qu'on mange ce soir chéri donc
forcément elle regarde un peu et elle
regarde voilà donc alors jean-luc je
reviens sur ce qui s'est passé dans
l'émission et je réponds aux questions
magnifique l'est ça du taffetas n'ont
cessé de nubuck
c'est ensuite une question bonjour je
m'appelle catherine vous tester
régulièrement des nouveaux chroniqueurs
mais au final c'est toujours les mêmes
qui reste vu leur qualité est ce parce
qu'ils sont pas chères dans cette
question chaque catherine mais non je
vous rassure il n'est pas question de
rémunération
s'il était bien clair là dessus surtout
pas d'argent entre nous sommes là c'est
juste que nous sommes les meilleurs les
seuls capables de réaliser des gestes
techniques très compliqué par exemple
les applaudissements à regarder thierry
et jean michel la concentration que ça
leur demande un nouveau jeu qu on a
travaillé à callac ans qui s'appelle le
jeu de la fin et oui ce sera dans un
instant
son côté applaudi s'ils sont contents
d'avoir été laissée la réducation grèce
non ça a l'air de rien mais c'est très
dur d'être chroniqueur dans une émission
de danse et médias il faut par exemple
savoir rire au bon moment on croit que
c'est spontané mais pas du tout c'est
l'entraînement le jour les culés vous
conseille aux lourds moi c'est le lourd
je suis désolé sortie de sortie de son
jeu s'il veut ne respect pas c'est plus
parce qu'ils supportent pas séparés
comme thierry moreau nous nous ça va on
est habitué à e1 nous sommes une équipe
venir directement tu veux munich et mama
robrig toi question m'est pas possible
je disais donc à part thierry moreau
nous sommes une équipe voir une famille
car comme le dit si bien jean michel on
veut pas dire qu'en un peu on sème on
est des frérots on s'entraide
la semaine dernière nous nous
retrouvions nous pour cette nouvelle
année 2014 et je vais trahir un secret
les vacances ont été douloureuses les
uns sans les autres
on se voit tellement que quinze jours
séparent et c'est compliqué
je vous ai manqué un palais oui oui tu
toi qui m'a manqué mois david heyman on
ça il faut expliquer il faut expliquer
la tomme de jean michel et très
sentimental s est achevée d'ici là c'est
parce que vous croyez jeté un objet
voilà qu'il a besoin sur lui mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec ce que vous targuez
satob s'attache vite aux gens et quand
elle ne les voit pas elle pleure en tout
cas est la goutte au nez
on n'a pas vu ça vous ennuie
ça va ça vraiment je vous rejoins là
dessus mais non heureusement c'était les
grandes retrouvailles et je vous rassure
en 2014
thierry moreau fera toujours des vannes
que jean-michel ne comprendra pas vous
vous souvenez la conversation ce faire
allez sur les tétons ah oui tu es ton
oui mais bel et bien un bas ça faisait
longtemps mais le muppet show est de
retour j'ai dit au lieu de dire bonne
année il faudrait dire bon ajout
je
toi du kenya peut-être dans les safaris
peuvent donc plus l'équipe est revenue
en forme à commencer par enora comme
d'habitude très en forme au pluriel
qu'est ce que vous savez et nora est
très joli mais ne mesure pas 1 mètre 80
donc quand elle va voir un invité pour
discuter
c'est très difficile pour lui de tenir
une conversation en la regardant droit
dans les yeux
si si regardez la preuve avec enrico
macias bien changé pas vous changez pas
rester comme hi hi hi ha la la
c'est magnifique la gauche n'est pas
bien donc ça devrait nous aurons une
d'enora facétieuse puisqu'elle a inventé
un nouveau jeu avec christophe carrière
1 le pétage de tympans vous allez voir
c'est très simple et le plus drôle dans
l'extrait suivant c'est qu'isabelle est
tellement loin dans sa tête qu'elle ne
voit même pas que ces deux voisins de
complot contre elle
à
la formule label chéri j'ai des images
de l'attentât ont ralenti si vous voulez
vraiment ralenti
elle qui est si gentil bon heureusement
elle n'est pas toujours assise à côté de
ses deux en soirée il fallait assise à
côté de gérard louvin à gérard louvin
qu'elle essayait de rassurer après qu'il
ait eu à porter un costume de florent
pagny alors il y a jean marc généreux et
ma ma petite femme jacqueline spencer
qui est la chorégraphe donc de
l'émission tout allait bien mais la
pluie a les bons amis les benjamines que
ta gueule toi didon kaunas je ne veux
pas le dire - mais on s'aime on est des
frères au centre est essentielle il a
arrêté à kaunas parce que je lui ai
répondu après c'est bien vous l'avez dit
un truc commence par e1 et qui se
termine par elle et on vous l'avait dit
v il faut savoir que en fait touche pas
à mon poste c'est la première crèche
pour adultes compose d'un crèche je suis
gentille parce que là même avec beaucoup
de bonne volonté il ya des échanges que
je ne comprends pas bon on sait que de
ce côté là un sel c'est très orienté
c'est le stand brushing vannes pourries
et cochonneries
mais de l'autre je ne sais pas comment
il a rien à voir ce genre de
conversation
et c'est très réussi c'est très beau
mais excusez moi mais est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui a une conversation
intelligente dans cette émission
peut-être tiré moreau lui était très
choqué le jour qu'on fasse venir du
raisin sur votre plateau car peu de gens
le savent mais thierry et très écolo
donc tout de suite une conversation éco
responsable là oui mais justement c'est
pas très écologique ce n'est pas la
période du raisin je me dis toi tu
penses pas écolo toi tu penses pas
développement durable parce que sa
gueule habitent ici s'y pense qu'à ça il
m'a poussé par un nom ensuite parfois
et les couverts 71,7 je voulais changer
de place non non c'est bien vous voulez
changer de place vous montrer ce qui se
passait de l'autre côté comme de l'autre
côté il se passer ça
lourdes
ils font les animaux est super content
d'être à côté vous faire une révélation
quand je des rushes les images pour
préparer cette rubrique
j'ai envie de partir loin en tout cas et
coup ces extraits on se dit que cyril a
bien du mérite à tenir sahara si on y
est obligé de jouer les pompiers en vous
invitez ne soit pas choqué par les
propos des chroniqueurs
le problème de cyril c'est qu'ils
trouvent toujours une formulation qui
peut prêter à confusion
tous les jus de toute façon du même
tonneau
au revoir merci
je voulais que ça sorte
non non non il n'y a pas d'accord pirard
des tirs
oui cyril dit parfois des choses
étranges dans l'émission comme lors de
la première de janvier
alors je leur passe car personnel a
compris cette phrase on a reçu beaucoup
de courrier vous allez vous expliquer on
se fera encore des ennemis on se fera
encore des amis même si on se fait plus
d'ennemis que d'amis dans cette émission
mais on se fera en tout cas des gens et
on dira ce qu'on pense sur la télévision
si vous avez quelque chose à 2014 aura
des gens
on se fera des gens parce qu'on aime les
gens aiment la proximité on aime les
changes tout simplement les accords très
naturellement david évaluations vous
choque
bon la vanille c'est un peu l'impression
un peu il n'est pas qu'on se fasse des
gens non chacun son truc
on vous le savez en tout cas ils la
belle aime danser en bas mais on pensait
que c'était juste pour son plaisir et
bat pas que c'est aussi une parade
nuptiale
regardez regardez bien son regard plein
de gourmandise pour djibril cissé pas
c'est furtif et on voit bien qu'elle le
drague
le problème c'est qu'il n'a jamais
calculé mais non on aime la regarder
alors pour bien commencer l'année une
nouvelle compil de saison oui
tu lui avais dit avant mais les chats
c'était bien pourri mais c'était très
drôle en plus il ya des tours il ya des
nouveautés cette année où le public va
être encore plus sollicités voilà j'en
profite même c
et vous dire les gens chez maier
m
lagardère qui clôt une dernière question
a dit allez on y va
bonjour je m'appelle nadia on dit femme
qui rit à moitié dans son lit donc je
voulais savoir si thierry moreau n'en
avait pas marre de dormir seul